the left wants to censor what you say to
control your decisions to tell you you
can only agree with them I believe in
the Constitution and the Bill of Rights
I believe in freedom at Ted Cruz that's
the right one right there there are
other there's so many ted cruz's that
seem official on the Twitter's at
senator Ted Cruz at Sen Ted Cruz but
just Ted Cruz at Ted Cruz's is the main
one that's the political one at Sen Ted
Cruz is official but at Ted Cruz
why don't you just you know have like
the people who take up all the other
titles have a couple of calls made I
would imagine you know it caused you
some problems you know like at Sen Ted
Cruz ish get rid of them it's look there
all sorts of crazy things on Twitter the
nuts thing is I read all the bad things
on Twitter why I don't know because it
you it gives you a sense of what's going
on Heidi thinks it's just that I'm a
masochist but I was gonna say that yeah
every time someone every nasty insult so
for every lefty out there let me see if
you actually have something clever and
funny yeah I'll like read it to the team
like if someone's like you know f you
it's like okay well that's very special
right you know a good insult that stings
is really funny those those are
hysterical by the way I've got to say I
saw a show you did recently of this
lefty who said he wanted a piece of you
that's a lot of them have to narrow it
down
jeanny and hunted him down I didn't hunt
let's be careful with the language there
because next thing I was gonna blame me
for creating a map no no I dressed as a
genie and granted his wish
yes hysterical I was doubled over I was
driving somewhere in Texas watching it
on my phone and doubled over laughs well
thank you very much I appreciate it
but back to the insults it's true one
was I think a Cuba Garrett knows someone
insults me one time since I'm like this
is about as terrible as that zit that
Crowder tried to clearly cover up and it
was true I had and I was like oh man
that's a beautiful burn it stings it's
worth it and we repost them but if it's
just vulgar and ain't it's not really
fun yeah okay well I'm glad to see these
easy you can appreciate let me look at
to see the sense of humor this side of
Ted Cruz so speaking about obviously
this this is a race right now I always
say for for people who don't know
there's you know Senate is is some it's
important in our government
I would advise they go check out
Schoolhouse Rock let me ask you this why
is it even being discussed as though
it's within striking distance with this
overt character well it's a crazy time
laughs they're really angry they're
filled with rage they're filled with
hatred for president Trump sure
and we're seeing that spill out
everywhere you look I mean we're saying
it you know this this past week Heidi
and I were confronted by screaming
protesters having dinner in Washington
and then right they basically shut the
restaurant down by screaming and yelling
and surrounding us and we see that kind
of nastiness just growing and growing
and growing well that kind of energy
it's politically it's dangerous because
what it means is tens of millions of
dollars are flooding into the state of
Texas that if you're on the far left and
you can defeat one Republican in the
country who's on the ballot it'd be me
yes and and so they're flooding the
state with cash and and well if your
goal is to defeat an actual consistent
conservative Republican yeah you know
they would be going after you and that's
what that's what bothers me about this
so much I don't really think it's nearly
as close as the media is trying to cover
it but you're not gonna get a prime spot
on Ellen the same way it's amazing that
these people who would never pay
attention to this race are putting all
of this momentum behind the guy just to
put them within you know I mean how
close do you really think this is do you
think it's as an example of Trump where
it won't even be close well look at the
polls Texas has been trending more per
so when I ran in 2012 I won the state by
16 points right in 2016 Trump won by
just over 8 points mm-hmm that's the
same margin he had in Ohio so nobody
thinks of Ohio as bright red unshakably
Republican I think that's true of Texas
- that's right that we have we got 28
million people we have a ton of liberals
we have a good ten million liberals in
the state of Texas now conservatives
outnumber them but you know you know go
down to Austin and and you know Travis
County is filled with as left-wing
people as you'll find anywhere and and
there are a lot of them and right now
you know anger is a dangerous motivator
right if you think about it on the right
in 2010 President Obama had been elected
he jammed through Obamacare II jam
through dodd-frank and a whole lot of
folks a whole lot of conservatives and
libertarians were ticked off he was
doing a lot of damage to the country and
we saw a tidal wave election in 2010 I
think we want something like 70 seats
and that's what's big that kind of
energy is dangerous
in part because it unifies you so folks
on the Left they may disagree on all
sorts of things are you a full-on
socialist or communist I mean they're
having those kind of right yes exactly
yeah or Marxist and I think the only
difference of that point is a beard or
the length thereof yes look there's a
Cuban I'm not gonna knock anyone for
having a beard
but look the anger lets them all be
unified they can all agree the hate
Donald Trump right and so that keeps
them together the danger on the right if
you look at the centre-right coalition a
conservatives libertarians independence
is one or two percent are miffed about
one thing and one or two percent or
miffed about something else right and we
may not be unified let me ask you this
how do you think it relates finally we
do have to let I know you're busy you
have to get to the airport to this
election I noticed I watched the debates
obviously not as many people watch these
debates as a presidential debates but
for people who didn't watch it huge
contrast you were talking about a policy
how well Texas has done yet in
comparison to further left states and
your opponent would opine get very
emotional talk about how he's had a DUI
and talk about how everyone needs to be
given a second chance have you noticed
that he's doing
obviously not accusing anyone of rape
but it's that similar emotional
grandstanding that's the contrast that I
see in this election well look there's a
lot of pattern on the far left where
they try to be they try to manipulate
people with emotion and they avoid facts
or logic or reason if you look at every
couple of weeks or a couple of days
rather we see a media puff piece of bait
O'Rourke and he's it's all rainbows and
puppies right it's just oh look at his
hair look at his teeth look didn't you
get arrested for burglary am I mistaken
I know the DUI just I think it's
burglary but not but arrested okay go
ahead I don't want to put you in home
but he's got great hair yes he does he
he and and the media is deliberately
trying to keep it warm and fuzzy and not
focus on substance that's actually what
I thought the debate was important
because substance matters I think Texans
are smart and our economy is booming I
mean it is going extremely well none of
Californians would have their way we'll
keep on moving I know you know and and
my approach is I'm gonna ignore the
personal attacks I'm not gonna do what
the Democrats did in the Cavanaugh
hearings and go into the gutter yeah I'm
gonna keep it focused on substance on
the issues and on substance and issues
his position is radical and it's bad for
Texas it is pretty radically left I'm
glad to hear you say it
you say well okay there's right I think
he's pretty radical it is typically in a
general election Democrats pretend to
run to the middle right this guy is
running to the left of Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren and I'll say you
know you've got a lot of folks watching
you who are libertarians yeah if you're
a libertarian at home this guy is a big
government status yeah he wants the
government in charge of everything he
wants full-on socialized medicine so the
government's in charge of your doctor
your health care he wants government
regulation he's he's voted in favor of a
$10 a barrel tax on every barrel of oil
in the state of Texas yeah now our
economy millions of jobs in the state
depend on energy and and he's perfectly
happy to just hammer it by the way that
works out for every one of us who drives
yeah to twenty four cents a gallon in
taxes that you'd pay but he watched
Deepwater Horizon once so he knows what
he's talking about no he's to the left
of Nina Pinta Santa Maria Cortez I think
that's important to know here's what I
always say to people listen I know we
gotta get going what I always say to
people is uh
Texas no state tax and a surplus for as
many years as I can count we've got it
right so go forward and vote it's at Ted
Cruz that's right one at Texas at Ted
Cruz and then Ted Cruz org is the
website and and Freedom Works that that
would be my closing words look for young
people why would you want some unelected
bureaucrat in Washington running your
life you ought to be free to choose to
choose your education to choose your job
to choose your free speech the left
wants to censor what you say to control
your decisions to tell you you can only
agree with them I believe in the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights I
believe in freedom and I think that most
young people in Texas and across the
country do as well we've turned the
tables on Al Gore and use the internet
to our advantage if you like this video
subscribe by hitting the subscribe
button or the notification bell next to
it because subscribing isn't enough
watch one of these other videos and you
know listen you can you can stick around
you don't have to but here's the thing
the fact that you're still listening to
me saying stick around as I say stick
around and you're sticking around bye we
just added another ad you just made me
for more sense